who could have predicted that one of the
internet's most elaborate fandom
communities would begin with a single
post on June 22nd 2007. uploaded on
4chan's paranormal export the statue
read like a government case File and
opened with a provocative warning
special containment procedures item
SCP-173 is to be kept in a locked
container at all times the entry
describes an animate and malevolent
figure made of concrete and rebar with
indications it had been spray painted at
one time it is housed in a large room
with unbarred Windows when a lone sounds
of stone scraping can be heard it will
fill its container with a mixture of
reddish brown material believed to be a
combination of feces and blood but the
scariest part blink and it will kill you
although the post would be deleted a few
days later the strange entries sparked
the imagination of the X Community
suggesting the existence of a secret
government organization dedicated to
collecting and containing preternatural
entities yeah that's the perfect start
for World building
I'm Dr Emily zarka and this is monstrum
this strange entry in 2007 was the
Genesis of what we now know as the SCP
Foundation a spooky fictional Universe
centered around a Wiki that hosts
thousands of posts from contributors
across the globe who contribute to its
lore SCP Foundation is crowd sourced
folklore at some of its finest and it
takes collaborative fiction to a whole
new dimension while it's tempting to
dismiss the SCP as some crazy conspiracy
website the administrators clearly and
frequently acknowledge that the
foundation is essentially an art and
creative writing experiment in their
words the foundation its anomalies and
everything else that's been written
about is fictional but that doesn't make
it any less fun quite the opposite
according to the lore the SCP Foundation
is a nebulous International group of
individuals who identify capture and
contain Supernatural and Prater natural
anomalies with the full support of every
every major national government kind of
like the Men in Black and Area 51 meets
The X-Files their official slogan we
secure we contain we protect objects
like the malevolent IKEA store Shy Guy
the old man or the endless staircase are
iconic to the foundation's lore if
you've been on any horror corner of the
internet you've probably felt the
lingering presence of the SCP in games
short films fiction and Fan Art part of
that is because instead of being behold
into copyright and ownership which can
restrict a story's ability to adapt each
SCP Universe entry is part of a
collective tradition that is ever
evolving and the lore spreads quickly
while many people rightfully tend to
hold older Legends and folklore in
reverence for their historical
significance and insights into evolving
communities the SCP Foundation offers
something more a unique perspective into
how stories and monsters evolve in real
time the community is open to any member
who would like to post most entries are
told through Case Files fiction written
in a pseudo-scientific report style that
details the special containment
procedures of the anomaly followed by a
detailed description of the event object
or entity and how it was contained each
of these entries is given a three or
four digit SCP number and brief title
some images may be included as well as
addendums that contribute to the
understanding of the artifact and how it
is affecting or responding to its
surroundings in more recent years
creative authors have even produced
interactive pages that evoke all sorts
of real-world Technologies unlike many
other fictional Supernatural
organizations the SCP Foundation is
incredibly bureaucratic which
contributes to a successful World
building bureaucracy is something many
of us are all well too familiar with and
utilizing this common cultural
understanding allows for a more ready
entry point into the foundation's world
supporting this connection is scp's
rhetorical style which mimics classified
government texts especially redacted
documents common themes can be found
throughout the foundation's many entries
fear or reticence of Technology viral
communication scientific or governmental
failure to control danger definitions of
sentience doppelganger and hybrid being
anxiety but that's just the tip of the
iceberg there's Josie the half cat
hidden exoplanets with alien life forms
a coffee vending machine that can
produce any liquid on demand a strangely
helpful star-shaped NightLight a pool of
what appears to be blood from which
extremely hostile entities occasionally
exit and the remains of a murdered woman
that cause horrific deaths and
disappearances these objects along with
thousands of others are labeled as one
of 11 object classes separated into
Common Primary classes and non-standard
object classes the categories range from
safe meaning threatening but easily and
safely contained with minimal
foundational effort to anomalies that
require massive effort to be dealt with
usually associated with a world-ending
threat objects in this class cannot be
contained are indestructible and and or
are expected to escape an object's class
is determined by the informal locked box
test according to Foundation lore most
autonomous alive and or Sapient objects
are at least Euclid class meaning you
can lock it in a box but you're not sure
what will happen the authors of these
texts are tapping into attention that
exists across many populations fear that
our governments may not be telling us
the whole story and raise questions
about if such information withholding is
productive or destructive and that's
exactly what the original 2007 4chan
post provided a story that Taps into
people's fears and mistrust of the
government as well as their ability to
contain their secrets safely we might
not have known the source of the
original
SCP-173 if it weren't for the online
sleuth Das meme who brought the original
entry back to the internet's awareness
after some archive searching in 2018.
fans of Doctor Who May note the
similarities between the weeping angels
and SCP-173 while this connection has
not been confirmed for Doctor Who fans
this narrative serves as an extension of
something that already exists in popular
culture but brings it into a larger
organization and hints At Its Real World
existence by using familiar bureaucratic
language and style administrators of the
wiki now note that SCP-173 is uniquely
inspiring because it relies on the fear
that emerges from Wonder and possibility
rather than a jump scare the original
five large threads that emerged on
4chan's X Forum in January 2008
dedicated to expanding the SCP Universe
became known as the SCP series the
popularity of the work was deemed
important enough or cool enough that on
January 19th someone made a Wiki for all
of the scp-themed posts that began
popping up so that the content wouldn't
be lost to the ether originally housed
on the edit this Wiki Farm anyone at any
time could edit the stories discussion
boards existed for every page user Fritz
Willy saw that stories were being
deleted by the edit this hosting Network
and moved the entirety of the
community's content to a wikidot which
went live on July 25th 2008. this move
introduced a page rating and comment
system and moderators were introduced
everything was still open source any
user could edit any post they wanted
until someone created spam threads and
started deleting stuff in Mass
longtime users decided to remove
Anonymous edits and an Administration
team emerged eventually to keep the
spirit of the original SCP series and
ensure that the quality of content was
maintained Banning was enacted and more
strict editing policies put in place the
community's dedication to preserving the
early work of the genre is not just
something I appreciate it's absolutely
crucial to establishing any kind of
standard or Canon for the genre I also
think it shows A really lovely
dedication to the foundations Community
the internet can often feel like a
lawless country but when it comes to the
SCP Foundation rules help preserve its
Integrity because most of the content
posted to the site is allowed to be
adapted recreated or reused the
foundation's universe has served as
inspiration for many other creative
works there was a theater contribution
to the lore welcome to the Ethics
Committee performed in Dublin a concert
in Glasgow various video games a
serialized novel in Japan and a graphic
novel while these elements testify to
the widespread popularity of the SCP
Foundation Universe its primary presence
online seems most important to its World
building the internet is inherently
liminal which can make sharing stories
that seem real but aren't more efficient
the scp's case File approach and vaguely
scientific rhetoric blurs the boundaries
between the real and the not real in a
space many people approach as both
permanent and nebulous virtual reality
is a ready space for Imagined realities
but that's not to say there aren't
educational lessons in The Archives of
the SCP or that they don't contribute to
social policing and understandings of
deviant Behavior like all Explorations
into monsters in fear it's about pushing
the boundaries of what scares or
unsettles us and why these elements are
even debated in the foundation's
discussion boards take something like
scp-1919 for instance a Euclid class
object that requires a containment
perimeter with a two kilometer radius
since it presents as a decaying early
20th century hotel and converted Mansion
if a human enters the building it
produces multiple humanoid replicas of
that person as well as anything they are
carrying for this reason Personnel
cannot carry body armor or weapons these
replicants are not perfect loans they
have physical abnormalities like sealed
nostrils or improper proportions that
mark them as replicants there are enough
of these that after Expedition 2 when
aggressive replicants referred to as
scp-19191 emerged there are apparently
enough of these that they function as a
coordinated ant colony made and
controlled by singular female being any
entry is currently halted until all men
at the stations can be expected to have
starved to death okay there's a lot to
unpack there but the hive zombie
mentality aggressive mob violence and
mysterious replicant leader call to mine
many real world fears of overpopulation
destructive group think and even Urban
Decay giving the buildings decrepit
appearance
but those are just my interpretations I
think that's where a lot of the Real
Genius comes from in the SCP Foundation
just enough information is given and
given impassively enough that your mind
goes crazy trying to fill in the blanks
there seemed to be no completed stories
or Case Files which means infinite
exploration of what scares us is
possible in my opinion in some ways
there is even greater potential for
legend growth and significance through
online Global communities like the SCP
Foundation they allow stories to
cultivate quickly and in nuanced ways
that translate their relatability across
disparate communities telling these
stories is performative a form of
communication that allows for others to
offer their own alterations to the text
in real time the appreciation for
recreating and retelling the stories
without fear of copyright infringement
is an interpretive Freedom that's
actually really powerful it Harkens back
to more traditional lore Evolution just
without Geographic or language
boundaries while we secure we contain we
protect is their official slogan dare I
add we teach while not an educational
tool by Design the collaborative format
can advance participants multimedia
communication skills the creative
guidelines open authorship and informal
peer review you process covers many of
the fundamental components of
traditional writing practices invention
collaboration drafting revision and
reflection those all happen in the SCP
Wiki it embodies storytelling methods
with digital media literacy is it a
substitute for formal writing course ASU
Professor Emily zarka PhD says no but it
can serve as a supplemental educational
tool especially for writers who may be
hesitant to jump into creative writing
spaces or for authors looking for a
community heck maybe it has a place in
my syllabus
SCP Foundation is building and
supporting a vibrant and creative
community that reformulates the crucial
human custom of Storytelling and lore
building and it has the added bonus of
being creepy AF an anonymity of reports
an
anonymity of reports I did it again
anonymity of reports there's too many
W's in a row